yo what is up everybody my name is
prestige and today i got something
pretty special for you now you see
orders in the jungle i'm creative we're
chilling
and i actually had today i have a
friend who is having a birthday and i
know they play minecraft i don't know
they know i do youtube so let's give
them a present
now you may be asking yourself what
in god's green earth is that
this is a tall
glass of ice cool lemonade with
strawberries in it
this is basically now with a birthday
candle this is basically my best attempt
at doing it so happy birthday to you
i'll call you miss case and so it really
makes sense to for me to use my your
name when you're not here
i do hope you see this video and i do
hope you have a great birthday and
here's your glass lemonade
but i know for all the rest of my fans
all the rest of the people watching my
videos
you guys don't want to see a 10 20
second video lemonade glass
so i have a amazing hunger games for you
it lasted seven minutes it consisted of
me killing
everybody in the game
and then a twist at the end
so i hope you guys enjoy that and i will
see you yo what's up guys this is
prestige here again with something that
i actually don't think i've done on my
channel and this is some minecraft
hunger games
so if you don't know what this is then i
don't know how
and
yeah so we're just gonna try and make
this a quick game and kill all the
peoples and yeah it'll be good stone
sword
that's what i'm talking about this one's
from the beginning come on come on
where'd he go here we go
there we go golden apple yes
some armor and golden apple we'll take
that i'll take that any day
um
is what is this guy doing what are you
doing
all right all right let's see let's see
let's see
let's kill some of these guys let's kill
you
come on
okay you didn't have anything on you oh
well
this is a growl this is an amazing start
to my first hunger games i'm serious
since i have never done hunger games on
my series
or i don't remember doing hunger games
i'm serious and you're gonna die
yep that's death for you
let's throw these iron boots on and oh
let's get over here
uh was there a chest around here i don't
know
well we are we he just went on a rampage
because we got that good old stuff
now obviously okay i see a guy over
there
probably won't know oh why to jump
hurt myself
let's try getting up this mountain what
the heck try getting up this mountain as
fast as possible
so that this guy does not escape our
grasp
oh he's over there
let's get the sword out let's do this so
yeah so i'll be doing this and we're
where'd he go
yo
where'd you go
i'll be probably maybe hopefully between
more of these oh he's down there
and if you guys like him that is if you
don't like him i won't do more if you do
i will i think he is he's a wooden sword
yeah
oh dad mid-air oh he had some iron on
him the iron drop i think the iron drop
well we got some
armor
let's go collect that iron since if we
get another piece and we get a stick
oh and some arrows yes oh oh fine it's
okay we got some vods
we good
and arrows and a chest plate there we go
we're buff very nice i'm running around
with this helmet now breeze island i
don't like it because people can hide on
the edges of the map for days and years
and it's just a little bit annoying
and we got lots of people up in this
vicinity this guy only has a wind sword
or he's doing little trickster moves but
alas he's going to die
don't worry i won't let lava kill you
awesome yourself fell in the lava though
that's your own fault
i'm just doing great i love it oh we
gotta fight over here do we do we no no
yeah yeah we do
i'll just kill you
this is great oh my gosh tons of arrows
you have a bow don't have a bow i'm
pretty sure this is better
oh i got sticks awesome i can make an
iron sword
i still i don't have a bow seriously
um yeah we're just seeing
what there is of our liking
we can spare thrown down this earth you
throw you throw you okay that's
basically it let's go make an iron sword
man i've never been this basically
there's one guy that like had like 1072
points and i think he had a thousand or
ten no yeah i was gonna say or ten
thousand no he didn't have ten thousand
points
and
iron sword there we go
and he was just gonna be the one
possible challenge ah he's alive the
lookout guy so actually we're really
close to deathmatch if i can just manage
to kill one more person
try
getting this oh gosh oh back up back up
oh that's him that's him that's him
okay i'm gonna eat this i'm gonna eat
this okay okay
okay
yeah he saw me eat that he's gonna eat
that so this is the guy this is the guy
yeah i know
oh you have no weapon and
wha what are you doing
why is this guy fighting me
88 yeah i got 88 points because he had
like a thousand points
i guess so it's not i don't think it's
doing um death match yet because there
weren't that many people to start with
that's what i've noticed okay there we
go three people left man this was this
was i don't even have iron armor i have
like
i've ironed boots
if you guys have iron armor they can
beat me
but see what that was
that was crazy that went so by so fast
well it's not over yet so oh what i got
a bow
when did i get a bow
what is
oh this is wet
yeah yeah
when did i get a bow
i don't even
remember actually i can make some arrows
i have time come on come on come on
let's do this let's do this come on
you can do this
come on sticks
no
like that
like that because we don't want to use
all our sticks no
40 arrows okay we're selling arrows i'm
just over stick left doesn't give me get
some diamonds or something
okay so we have him and him okay i'm
gonna get this guy first
that guy doesn't even seem to have a bow
yeah
haha you're good
winning
went in
oh my gosh on fire
hey stop moving
oh bro okay the other guy isn't even
playing
oh is he
oh i can hit i can hit either of them
i feel like this guy just didn't meet
anybody the entire time he was playing
dude my bow is wrecking okay there he
goes
at first when he said he died i thought
i didn't get any points
okay i have an iron sword
and okay okay he can kill me if i don't
get any hits off oh no screw this
oh
i'm totally op and i get killed okay
oh gee oh that was a great game i hope
you guys enjoyed
i didn't win but uh i got 88 points for
killing lockout
and so yeah hope y'all enjoyed if you
did leave a like comment rate subscribe
if you want me to do more of this stuff
and i'll see you all later peace out